you will not return Raptors in the sense
of the screen a roll step through
gorgeous back cut lap fudge oh here it
is again a screen a roll beautiful
drawing kick blended and Adobe with the
pole that's his third
piles into the frontcourt
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a favorable match robot co2 is
six the block peyote leave pass now Jade
knock down two or three concessions
deflected scooped up numbers three on
one
oh gee back to Noah just good unselfish
basketball and everybody running CJ
Miles running along with the other two
[Music]
[Applause]
gianna no be I did in a turnover the
11th
good job by Valanciunas cutting off
caliber old G which is steep Booker up
top tonight by surge ahead now ot and no
be the reverse slam dunk in once again
defense leading to offense and a NATO
run mission defense table serge ibaka
takin care of business and the rapper's
taken off and OG and an OB thrown the
doubt they can test that time by Ibaka
McGee's on the able to get it to go
here's oh Deena Nobby knocks it down the
3-pointer running and finding the open
man
Raptors still somehow get it in the mass
pasture minute left here in the first
half spin move ot two-handed slam seven
at one point miss for them no Kawhi
Leonard for the second consecutive game
for the Toronto Raptors they get a
turnover opportunity out of the break
Lowry step back pulls up drains it foul
on Kyle out
there Kyle just so cool with a shot
right here coming down the transition
three makes a huge difference look at
this ot OG puts it up and through and
he's foul than the Raptors that hasn't
gone oh and for at home to begin a
season since 1974-75 kind of like that
little fake to used a lot right and
[Applause]
Raptors with Oh Gianna no be keep three
and it's good feeling it we're just made
it your way through this until you find
your legs right reverse slam huge piece
to what they're trying to build in New
York
oh gee two-handed slam
he's it Shoji likes his matchup strong
that's something we did the safe emoji
last season trying to get him up a
little bit to play the defensive
CJ with the steel canner gets back
behind the back come on now Oh G get it
going faster starts with the beat
CJ Miles doing a great job getting it up
the floor check out oh gee the trailer
ready for the and-one the denied by og
minobii what great anticipation what
Nicollet NICUs looking for going small
getting aggressive forcing the defense
out for over
we talked about before with Nick nurse
because of his background in the G
League he's had to take a look at a lot
of different combinations and has seen a
lot of different scenarios because what
they're thinking right now
Raptors trying to speed it up and the
denial Oh G
[Applause]
that is his fourth they just play
through they will continue to fight as a
excellent job whose second topology is
pick no CJ Miles tonight no Serge Ibaka
Raptors lead by three Oh G finds Brett
mentor own let's see they were looking
for
but and it all be knocks it down that
his foot was on the line the two pointer
is a shot clock expires stupid I'd to
the right side you're going to see these
why don't you say well where's the
defender that's because when you
double-team watching a first-place team
team with the best record in the NBA you
know Gianna no be two-handed slam bam
bleep behind the back
[Applause]
at the end of the corner when you've got
the bench playing like this rush this
team is going to continue to get better
- gee thought about the three and trying
to back in on Wade see the weights got
old man oh gee
trying to back weighted weights and not
gonna work yeah no I'm not gonna work oh
jeez I got some Florida the double comes
scooped up by ot the reverse hand one
the pass was deflected record slicing to
the bucket
get into some offensive rhythm nice pass
Oh Gianna dovey there you go we got CJ
Miles making plays Oh Gianna no B
there's McConnell sidestep to impede
that threw it too far
and an OB season-opening leans in on a
shot okay yeah and you want him putting
the ball on the floor and you can see
Carol moving in underneath oh gee that's
a close lockdown sabonis turnover
Raptors your opportunity here good job
by siakam gives it to OG he's gonna pass
it in drive it in most up all kinds of
ways here's og post up a little while
ago against Dellavedova would you do a
nice job a spinning blade sends it out
to og an Adobe five-point lead
long take Oh T ties the season highs got
17 files in the corner Brown
lockdown
[Applause]
Gianna mobi wasn't shooted instead Texas
[Applause]
Raptors trailing 67 to 50 og diving
takes it away from olymic trailed 6750
at the 86 Hall what a move on the rim
and then a row takes it spins too strong
Oh G kicks it out Kauai drills it
Raptors great on the offensive glass
three opportunities it leads to a great
up the limo today and all the fans
waiting to be right there I don't know
if you see that but is incredible just
being next to your variable
oh gee and a no big rule I keep doing
that
Crowder's got the strength but jakub's
got the life and he's got to take
advantage over oh gee
and here's Pat's guy with a two-handed
slam oh gee Nov you know he comes in a
game he knows his job is to get after a
defense of a great job there aren't
angles and then the pass to Pascale see
a couple who knows what to do in the
open court Popovich said he knew it
would take some time for his team to
come together and he loved this
attention to detail great pass right
there great finish by Monroe going to
get more 1412 in seven tonight oh gee
with an attempt emoji drives with a move
but doesn't now for an Adobe lead by one
fans on their feet
[Applause]
shot doesn't go up
[Applause]
we pass
and for the Toronto Raptors taking out a
Brooklyn team currently seventh in the
East nice and here's that pass we saw
from Greg Monroe perfectly time cut by
Koji who throws it down and the four
minutes left in a 15-point game no gene
now backing in on Reed spins your pass
tipped away oh gee now attacks count it
and a foul
Oh Jew took a quick look clock at seven
oh gee side sent the defense by Brown
taking it on the inside what a strong
powerful move by og ananova elation
heavy offense a couple years ago and
what it is now as it continues to evolve
with Kawhi Leonard and an OB with an
Antwon it to og screen set by Monroe
rolls ball fake
and an OB great ball fake and then gets
to the red impressed by blue little
man's kicks I gotta give this to credit
danke steps out of bounds that jumper
down and they've only committed one
turnover thus far and again it's just a
little too easy is it since Brett Brown
is not happy you can get a stop here
four point game at halftime two point
game
oh gee with the steal drive
[Music]
gianna no as Marc Gasol clearing out
some space for and then the nice job
with the pic and a strong finish right
there could have been a foul Gasol at 11
points 11 of his 16 in the fourth border
against Brooklyn here's Joe GE off this
to go lid with a rebound see if the
Raptors can get something off of the
deed into the air you go
a pass and just do whatever they want
offensively this a beautiful play great
run
Portis gets it back on the Ron Pascale
gives it to og
[Applause]
talking about I don't know what my
proclamation of the defense picking up
is gonna actually happen I'm starting to
think that might not happen they are
very hard dunking is not hard you ever
know they 12 assists now for deer and
Fox on the replay board a boat support
and an OB from downtown
sort of a walk through to try to work on
things but as you know you don't
practice you get slippage and the areas
on both ends of the floor they see I
couldn't gets out on the break goes up
contestant blackout's Wayne Ellington
denied my booty Anna no be under a
minute remaining in the opening quarter
ot and and OB ahead now Pat's cow with a
slam dunk
what have we mentioned earlier or
Toronto check this out would you had an
OB get the hand in
and right away soon as he got control to
basketball I picked his head up didn't
waste another dribble you know exactly
what you want in different situations
that develop ot a nano beach good look
right here but the CETA pass just a
little bit behind and wall running and
it Williams and a steal by an anova
here's PAL numbers flowery land matchup
to watch yo G as well yeah look at this
one this way hangs in the air ships that
ball from one side of it tougher and
throws it down and that's a big-time
play right there decisions you make POW
slam-dunk good feed from og vault that
last offensive possession gives a man
who just loves the game of basketball
business see that wave as you see I know
you've knocked on that long or
with the rebound time in school let's be
smart good shots drives butts up a shot
of course that but it works he's at his
best when he's popping all over the
floor explosive count it and the foul
how bout OG they got a beautiful working
relationship in chemistry in that back
foot rafters head in one when they start
now witnesses og
across the timeline as onew tries to cut
him off Oh Janet oh my Morland chris
boucher as well and the fourth quarter
I was talking to chris boucher before
the game he says I'm ready Beijing with
14 points well I think it has nothing to
do with what he hasn't done I think it
goes to how much the other guys have
done by giannis like harden in win
[Music]
we underneath what is quick hops nice
job of getting there backing down see a
tremendous shot doesn't fall here's OG
an Adobe signed a 10-day March 30th
here's ot with a strong taking no be
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content